- On est carrément en interview.
- Ah, merde.
Non, y a pas de souci.
- Avec la clope et tout ?
Ouais, c'est pas grave.
C'est Brut ! C'est...
Salut, les amis, j'espère
que vous passez de bonnes vacances.
Salut, c'est Jason.
Kev Adams,
je te demande pas si tu connais.
Let's go !
Humoriste, acteur,
producteur, scénariste...
On lui a toujours collé l'étiquette
du jeune qui s'est fait
pistonner, etc.
Par qui, je sais pas.
Pourtant, c'est un mec qui s'est
créé en passant par des galères
comme toi et moi.
Après, moi, je galère encore.
Est-ce que ça compte ?
C'est pas grave.
Salut à tous.
J'espère que tout le monde va bien.
En tout cas, Kev,
ce que j'aime bien avec lui,
c'est que ses échecs,
il les assume à fond.
Il en parle sans filtre.
Aujourd'hui, t'en es pas
à ton 1er film.
Mais qu'est-ce qui t'a donné envie
de faire ce film ?
Ah, les bâtards,
ils ont tout éteint.
Ils ont tout éteint.
OK, ils veulent vraiment pas de moi,
aujourd'hui.
Dans le film, à un moment, y a
une phrase qui dit que la douleur
que t'as en toi,
c'est ça qui fait ta force.
T'as raison.
"Y a pas de super-héros
sans moments sombres."
Ta force, c'est ta douleur.
Moi, je crois à ça.
Moi, j'ai fait des spectacles,
frérot, devant 2 personnes,
pendant vraiment des années.
On parle de 3 piges de ma vie
où tous les soirs j'étais
sur mon scooter à chialer,
avec un vieux 50 cm³
qu'il fallait que j'aille
faire réparer,
mais j'avais pas la thune
pour le faire réparer.
J'ai dû faire...
plus de 1000 castings dans ma vie.
Ouais.
J'ai passé tous mes mercredis
et mes samedis, de mes 12 ans
à mes 20 ans,
à être dans des putains
de salles à attendre
avec un texte de 3 pages à la main.
Avec 15 autres gars qui étaient là.
Je l'ai fait toute ma vie.
Et toute ma vie, on m'a dit :
"On vous rappellera."
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
- C'est violent, cette phrase.
Et un jour, je me suis réveillé,
j'ai dit : c'est pas moi.
Ça y est,
vous allez plus me rappeler.
Vous me rappellerez plus.
C'est moi, je vous rappelle.
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
- Ouais, je vois.
Et tu sais, moi, parfois,
ça m'a fait souffrir aussi.
Genre, j'ai cette image de : lui,
il a grandi avec une cuillère
en or dans la bouche.
Alors que pas du tout.
J'ai un reup qui s'est tapé toute
sa vie pour vendre des téléphones
sur les Grands Boulevards.
Ma mère, elle travaillait
à la BNP Paribas.
Vraiment, tu sais, dans les bureaux,
là où ils sont 200.
Où tous les jours, je l'entendais
rentrer à la maison et dire :
"J'en peux plus de ce travail,
ça me fait souffrir."
Après, j'ai commencé à connaître
le succès,
mais ça a été super violent.
J'ai été élevé par mon grand-père
qui a été un des seuls de ma famille
à croire en ça.
Il me disait :
"Bats-toi. Tu vas y arriver."
Il est décédé juste avant
que je commence à faire ce métier.
Donc pour moi,
t'imagines la souffrance.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un mec, toute ta vie,
c'est le seul de ta famille
qui te dit :
"Toi, t'es fait pour ça.
Tu vas y arriver."
Et le mec, il décède juste
avant que tout ça arrive.
Il m'a jamais vu sur scène,
tu vois ?
Euh, j'ai vécu le divorce
de mes parents,
qui peut paraître anodin,
mais c'était quand j'avais 20 ans,
à un moment très dur,
très particulier.
Je commençais à avoir du succès
sur scène et en même temps,
ma famille partait en lambeaux,
explosait dans tous les sens,
avec mes petits frères
qui étaient très jeunes.
Ça a été une grande souffrance,
et puis voilà, et puis tant d'autres.
Mais j'ai envie de te répondre :
comme tout le monde.
Tout le monde a ses histoires.
On a tous nos galères,
on a tous nos histoires.
On a tous eu des soucis.
Et cette souffrance-là,
quand t'arrives à t'en nourrir
et à en faire une force, je pense que
ça peut t'emmener très loin.
Je me rappelle d'un film que je suis
parti voir : Gangsterdam...
- Ouais !
- Qui n'a pas marché.
- Non.
Comment tu fais pour te relever ?
Tu perds un rein ou tu te relèves.
C'est comme ça.
J'ai tout donné pour ce film,
Gangsterdam.
Je pense que... encore aujourd'hui,
je pense que c'est un bon film.
Je pense que si demain,
il passe à la télé, les gens,
ils vont passer un putain de moment.
Mais qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ?
T'avances.
J'espère que dans ma vie,
j'en ferai plein, des films.
Y en aura des bien,
y en aura des pourris.
C'est comme ça. C'est la vie.
C'est pas grave.
Tu sais,
si j'avais la science infuse,
si j'avais le génie absolu,
ça se saurait.
Je l'ai pas.
Je fais ça avec mon cœur.
Des fois, je vois un film,
je me dis : ça me fait kiffer,
ça me fait gol-ri,
j'ai envie d'y aller, j'y vais.
Bien sûr que ça fait du mal,
les échecs.
Mais en temps, c'est là
que t'apprends le plus.
Dans les succès,
t'apprends pas grand-chose.
Les succès,
tout le monde est là,
tout le monde vient te cer-su :
"Putain, bravo,
t'as fait un truc super."
Mais ça veut rien dire.
Un échec, c'est là que tu vois
le vrai visage des gens.
C'est là que tu vois
le vrai visage du métier.
Ceux qui sont contents
de t'écraser.
Ceux qui sont... Tu vois ?
Et t'apprends. T'apprends.
Souvent, les décisions
qui nous amènent à échouer,
c'est celles qu'on prend en pleine
vitesse sous le coup de l'émotion.
Kev, il en a déjà fait les frais.
Et à cause de ça, il considère
qu'il faut réapprendre à vivre.
C'est vrai.
Je sais pas si toi, ça te parle,
mais moi, ça me parle.
Est-ce que quand t'as des échecs,
tu te dis que t'es allé trop vite ?
Parfois. Parfois, oui.
Moi, je parle avec des potes à moi,
qui ont entre 25 et 30 piges...
y a pas un moment de la journée
où on n'est pas en train de faire
un truc et ils me disent :
"On fait quoi, après ?"
Tout le temps.
C'est vrai ou pas ?
Tu parles avec des jeunes,
t'es là, je sais pas,
tu joues à la Play,
il dit : "On fait quoi, après ?"
Bah, attends, frère, viens,
on joue à la Play.
Là, on est en train de faire
un truc, déjà.
Parce qu’il y a une espèce
d'insuffisance.
Y a une nouvelle génération.
La nouvelle génération,
celle qui arrive, t'as vu comment
elle consomme les choses ?
T'as vu TikTok ?
Ta tin, ta tin, ta tin...
Faut que ça aille vite.
Attire mon attention
ou barre-toi de là.
C'est ça, la génération
dans laquelle on vit.
Donc je pense qu'effectivement,
faut qu'on réapprenne
à prendre notre temps et à vivre
le moment présent à fond.
Parce que putain,
y a que ça de vrai.
On sait pas, ni toi ni moi,
de quoi demain est fait.
On sait pas si on arrivera
à réaliser nos rêves.
On sait pas si ce qu'on a fait
avant était bien ou pas bien.
Ce qu'on sait,
c'est que là, maintenant,
en ce moment, on est ensemble
et qu'il faut le vivre à fond.
Ça, j'y crois.
- C'est ouf ce que tu dis,
parce que, en fait, tu parles
de réapprendre à vivre
et juste avant, tu parlais de...
T'as vu, en fait, échouer,
on a l'impression que c'est la fin
de la vie, or que c'est là en fait,
qu'on apprend le plus.
C'est bien connu.
C'est pas moi qui te l'apprends.
C'est quand tu te prends des pains
dans la gueule, quand tu tombes,
quand tu tombes, quand tu tombes...
que, au bout d'un moment,
tu te dis : OK, je crois que j'ai capté.
Je crois que là,
j'ai compris quelque chose.
Thomas Edison, il a déposé
un tas de brevets avant d'inventer
l'ampoule électrique.
Les échecs servent de répétition
au succès.
En fait, pour faire court, l'échec,
c'est le fondement de la réussite.
Kev, il a pas inventé
l'ampoule électrique,
mais il a mis du temps
avant de voir la lumière.
Et est-ce que t’as peur de la mort,
du futur, au final ?
J'ai peur de la mort.
Du futur, non.
Non, j'ai pas peur du futur.
Moi, je crois profondément à ça.
Chacun ses croyances.
Moi, pour moi,
Dieu est aux commandes.
Les choses se font comme elles
doivent se faire.
Ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'il faut pas forcer
les choses.
Mais par contre, faut se réveiller
tous les matins en se disant :
j'y vais, j'ai les crocs,
je vais rien lâcher.
Et une fois que t'as ça,
tout le reste ne dépend plus
vraiment de toi, tu comprends ?
Tout le reste dépend de l'énergie
que tu vas déployer,
que tu vas envoyer
et si ça paye, c'est bien,
si ça paye pas, ça va venir.
Voilà comment moi,
je vois les choses.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
- Totalement.
Pour moi, c'est soit j'y arrive,
soit je recommence.
Tu lâches jamais.
Soit j'y arrive,
soit je recommence.
Ouais, c'est comme ça.
Je suis comme ça depuis
que je suis tout petit.
Soit j'y arrive,
soit je recommence.
C'est pour ça que des fois,
je vois des injustices.
Des fois, y a des gens
qui me disent...
des journalistes, ils me disent :
"Ça a été facile, pour vous.
Vous êtes devenu star à 18 ans.
C'est facile."
Je dis : "Frérot, t'as pas idée, toi.
Toi, t'as..."
À 10 ans, j'étais déjà
un ouf dans ma tête.
À 10 ans, j'étais déjà en mode :
comment je vais y arriver ?
Putain, comment ? C'est tout.
Mais sinon, j'ai galéré
comme tout le monde.
J'ai eu des coups durs
Et j'aurai, dans le futur,
des échecs et des succès
comme tout le monde, tu vois
ce que je veux dire ?
Je suis pas plus
ou moins qu'un autre.
Mais par contre, je lâcherai ap.
Ça, c'est sûr.
Franchement, parler échec
avec Kev, c'est du lourd.
On s'envoie des bons messages
de motivation, tout ça, c'est cool.
Mais... j'ai oublié un truc,
en fait.
Mais tu connais,
on apprend le métier...
On est des débutants.
On n'a pas fait d'école, nous.
Moi, ce qui m'intéressait,
c'était parler love.
Savoir un peu c'était comment,
tu vois, à ce niveau-là.
Et franchement...
je m'attendais pas à ça.
Est-ce que c'est plus facile
maintenant ou avant, les amours ?
Franchement, j'ai pas
de réponse à cette question.
Je sais pas.
Je sais pas,
j'ai même l'impression que...
le statut de re-sta, parfois,
c'est même presque handicapant,
tu vois.
Et puis, est-ce que ça existe
vraiment encore ?
Moi, j'ai l'impression que y a plus
de stars dans notre époque, tu vois.
J'ai l'impression
que de moins en moins.
Regarde.
On regarde des séries Netflix.
Tu sais pas comment ils s'appellent,
les gars, dans les séries Netflix.
Et tu les adores.
Et tu kiffes la série.
Je pense qu'on est amenés
à se diriger vers un monde
où y aura moins cette espèce
de vedettariat, quoi, tu vois.
Ce côté : ouais, y a les vedettes,
puis les moins vedettes.
Des fois, je suis avec mon frère,
on marche dans la rue,
il me dit :
"T'as vu qui c'est, lui ?"
Je lui dis : "Qui c'est ?"
Il me dit : "C'est Tishmak."
Je dis : "C'est qui, Tishmak ?"
Il me dit : "6 millions sur TikTok."
Il fait pas un seul TikTok
qui fait pas des millions de vues.
Je sais pas qui c'est.
Je lui dis :
"C'est quoi, le talent de Tishmak ?"
Il me dit :
"Rien, il reprend des sons.
Il fait des...
Il tape sur les murs."
Je lui dis : "Mais..."
Dès que je rencontre un mec
entre 15 et 25 ans dans la rue,
il me dit : "Oh, putain, 6 millions
sur Insta, mec, c'est lourd !
C'est lourd."
Ça veut dire que pour lui,
c'est un accomplissement.
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
Ça veut dire quelque chose.
Et dans ce monde-là,
moi, j'essaie de jouer le jeu.
Parce que je pense que si tu vas
contre ça, bah...
t'es mort, t'as perdu.
Et moi, j'aime trop ce métier
pour l'arrêter, donc j'essaie
de jouer le jeu,
je donne un peu de TikTok,
je donne un peu d'Insta,
je donne de la photo, je donne...
Tu vois, j'essaie de donner un peu.
Je fais un peu de Twitter.
Léger.
Je donne un peu, léger, tu vois ?
Pour attirer vers des projets
qui me tiennent réellement à cœur.
Si je commence à être en mode :
"Ah, bah, c'est un film.
Vous voulez savoir
ce qui se passe ?
Bah, vous avez..."
Bah, non, t'es mort.
Soit tu joues le jeu,
soit t'es out.
Et même si tu joues le jeu, t'as
une belle chance d'être out
dans pas longtemps, quoi,
c'est comme ça.
C'est comme ça.
Ça marche, OK.
Bah, merci beaucoup, Kev.
Bah, avec plaisir, Jason.
Toujours un plaisir.
Je me suis assis, parce que,
franchement, je suis KO.
Tu vois les petits biscuits
dans les restaurants chinois
avec un petit message
à l'intérieur ?
Un jour, j'en ai ouvert un
qui disait comme ça :
"L'échec est la mère du succès."
Au passage, dédicace à toutes
les mamans et à la mienne.
Force à toi.
Pas facile d'avoir un fils
comme moi, mais bon,
on fait avec ce qu'on a.
À toi et à vous qui me regardez,
croyez en vous,
croyez en vos rêves,
et je vous souhaite
un tas d'échecs,
parce que c'est comme ça
que la réussite, elle va venir.
Force à vous !
Ah oui, j'oubliais :
abonne-toi à la chaîne Brut.
Et si t'as des personnes
que tu veux que je contacte,
t'as un influenceur que tu kiffes,
tu veux que j'aille lui parler,
t'as un footballeur,
tu veux que je lui parle,
t'as un danseur,
t'as un président,
tu veux que je lui parle ?
Envoie-moi un DM,
mets en commentaire sur YouTube,
peu importe.
Mais viens, on discute ensemble.
Viens, on parle.
Viens, c'est notre chaîne.
Viens, on se tape des barres.
Et viens, c'est que nous.